welcome back to Street talk just a
little bit of housekeeping before we
kick off today Paulina silivadov is one
of the organizers for a charity AI
conference called AI helps Ukraine now
their main goal is to raise funds for
Ukraine both from the folks attending
the conference and also from companies
sponsoring the conference and it's not
too late to sponsor the conference and
support it so please do if you possibly
can now all of the funds that they raise
will go to Ukraine medical support which
is a Canadian non-profit organization
which is specializing in humanitarian
aid for Ukraine now they have some of
the world's leading AI experts keynoting
at this event so Joshua Benjo Tim Nick
gabrue maxwelling Regina Basile Alexi
ephros and also one of our own personal
favorites here on mlst Professor Michael
bronstein the one and only now the
conference is online pretty much from
now until the 6th of December and is
being hosted from Mila in Montreal their
goal is to raise a hundred thousand and
dollars and they really really need the
support of the AI Community to club
together and and to just donate anything
that you can so we'll link to the
conference in the video and the podcast
description please donate if you can and
also share the links on on your socials
um now I'm at nurips this week in New
Orleans so I'll be walking around with a
camera uh please just um you know just
bump into me and and if you want to
record any spicy takes on artificial
general intelligence then you know let's
do it
um today is a conversation with Joshua
Bach who's one of our most requested
guests ever we recorded the conversation
back in April which gives you a bit of
an indication of of our backlog I can
only apologize about the backlog Keith
and I recently started a new Venture
called X-ray and as you can imagine
we've been working around the clock
coding uh just trying to trying to get
that business off the ground but when
we've made our Millions we'll devote all
of our time to producing amazing content
on mlst so yeah please bear with us
loads and loads of cool content coming
your way soon I hope you enjoy the show
today
peace out Dr Joshua Bach is our most
requested guest ever Joshua Bach is a
cognitive scientist focusing on
cognitive architectures models of mental
representation
emotion motivation and sociality
yahshua's interview on Lex podcast he
did he did two interviews on Alexis
podcast have been watched over two
million times so far which is just
absolutely unreal now Yeshua I've
watched many of your interviews and I
still don't feel that I have a firm
grasp on some of your views so today if
you don't mind I hope we can do a tour
de force over some of your most
important views in our shared space to
the extent that we can keep up with you
of course now um for example we'd like
to discuss go Dell and computation
Consciousness digital physics Free Will
and determinism large statistical models
and indeed whether they're AGI or a
parlor trick or something more esoteric
now when people talk about God or
Consciousness or any other complex
phenomena
it relates to everyone and it means
something different to everyone it's
ineffable and every conversation sounds
like a typical post-ketamine discussion
which is to say extremely low
information content now the topics we're
discussing today are very complex and
often we're reaching for the best
language to use to conduct the
conversation so I hope we do well today
anyway uh Dr Joshua bark is an absolute
honor to finally welcome you to mlst
thank you very much I'm glad to be on
the show
amazing well um when I started doing
computer science many years ago
interestingly the theory of computation
wasn't even on the curricula and I was
wondering whether you thought it should
be I mean presumably you think it's
extremely relevant for AGI now we want
this to be as pedagogical as possible so
please explain everything like with five
what does computation mean to you
I think that computation is far easier
than most people think it means that you
have a causal structure where every
transition can be decomposed into
individual steps and when we talk about
computational models we decompose the
world into States and transitions
between the states
and then it turns out that there is
certain minimal system that is able to
execute everything and this can be
described in many ways the most famous
one is probably the duration and the
many other ways in which you can
describe the turing machine for instance
you can just do the turing machine by
doing
um search and replace on strings and
this is how the Lambda kythonis is
defined and all the programming
languages in the Lambda calculus and the
turing machine turn out to have the same
power that is if you can compute
something with one of these paradigms
you can compute it with the others as
long as you don't run into resource
constraints so as long as it still fits
into memory and you don't care about
speed they all have the same power but
in practice of course every system is
limited so we don't run things forever
we want them to give us a result after a
certain time so what matters is what can
be efficiently contributed not what it's
reachable at all
foreign
and we're going to get into this a bit
but there are some possible loopholes at
least in uh you know let's say whether
or not the universe is is limited
um in in certain ways that the
definitions of like turning machines are
and one I wanted to ask you about
specifically is uh penrose's claims and
so he claims that what girdles work in
fact proves is that the human mind can
understand truths that are not provable
so specifically one can show that uh you
know given go to sentence is necessarily
true given given the mathematical
analysis even though it can't be proven
within the formal system that it's that
it's defined and Penrose claims that
this capability to understand if you
will to mathematically understand is in
fact non-computational at least in part
and so if he's right then our brains
might be what uh Turing referred to as
Oracle machines these are computers that
have access to a non-computable Oracle
or function that they can then utilize
those Oracles in order to perform hyper
computation essentially so I'm asking
I'm curious are you open to this
possibility and if not what is your
response to penrose's arguments
I suspect that Guru has been
misunderstood by a lot of philosophers
girdle was a true realist that is he
thought that truth really exists out
there that it's a thing that is eternal
in some sense you have this very strong
intuition in mathematics classically is
also formalized in this way the
difference between mathematics and
computation at least in the standard
sense in which we normally teach
mathematics at school is that
mathematics has no States
everything in mathematics just is
eternally
right it's it's a single state and if
you want to go through the sequence of
States you put an index into the formula
and uh but still everything is there at
the same time the index is just a way to
access this thing and this way of having
mathematics stateless is very elegant
because it allows us to Define functions
that have Infinity many arguments right
if you would have a state machine that
tries to consume infinitely many
arguments it would never finish before
it goes to the next step and the same
thing in the middle of the function if
you would compute something if it's
stateless you can just compute all the
indices all at once even if it's
infinitely many In classical mathematics
in a computational system you would have
to do this maybe one after the other and
if you would in parallel you will have
lots of CPUs running in parallel right
so you run into limits and the same
thing with the output so in the
classical mathematics you can chain
infinitely many steps in functions and
exchange Infinity many arguments but of
course mathematicians never did this in
practice it's just the specification
this is how they like to write things
down then they want to calculate it they
still have to go down and do it
sequentially step by step it's just
mathematics is defined in such a way as
if you could offload this to some
supernatural being or some grad student
who is going to do the infinitely many
calculations
and Guru took the specification of
mathematics and he found out that when
you have this stateless mathematics you
can for instance Define self-referential
statements that change the truth value
depending on the statement itself in
this recurrence leads can lead to a
contradiction in the state itself so you
basically get two statements which say I
am wrong and if by referring to itself
it changes its own choice value
right so if mathematics is stateless you
now run into a conflict in a
computational system that's not a big
problem your computer is not going to
crash if you write it down the right way
it just happens is that you choose value
fluctuates in every execution step it's
not going to converge
but this is not the real truth right who
is something that doesn't change when
you call it a call the function again
right so this what's going on here and I
think what Google has discovered is that
classical mathematics doesn't work
but you cannot build is any kind of
mathematics doesn't allow you to build a
machine
the hypothetical abstract machine Any
kind of universe that runs the semantics
of the classical mathematics without
crashing yeah but but it kind of seems
like okay we're gonna believe
girls youth of math use of mathematics
to prove that mathematics is flawed like
there seems to be almost an inherent
contradiction in there like you either
believe mathematics and thus you believe
girdle's proof of of you know some
specific limitations on computational
systems right or you believe that
somehow mathematics is flawed in which
case you can't trust the proof that
mathematics is flawed
I think girdle's conclusion was that
there is something fundamentally going
wrong that there might be an ability of
mathematics to describe reality and if
you believe that truth is real and it
exists independently of the procedure by
which you calculate it
then this seems to be plausible and it
was also the conclusions a lot of
philosophers have drawn from this which
basically write girls proof and
concluded that mathematicians have
admitted that their Arcane techniques
are important to describe reality and
therefore philosophers who don't
understand mathematics have a clear
advantage
of course this is not the conclusion uh
instead what turns out is that if we
just skip the or if we drop the original
classical notation or as understanding
of mathematics and replace it by
computation basically we say truth is
what you calculate with the following
procedure
and you can Define any kind of procedure
that you want you just have to make sure
that it converges to some kind of value
in the way that you want then you
resolve your problem it's just that you
lose your notion that tools is
independent of that procedure and so in
some sense the classical mathematics is
a specification that cannot be computed
from the perspective of computer
scientists this happens all the time
some customer wants you to build
something that cannot be built and you
have just proven that it cannot be built
right it doesn't mean that you cannot
build something useful and I think that
Penrose belief that our brain is
actually doing these infinite things
and it's not when we reason about
Infinity we are not actually reasoning
about infinitely many steps what we do
is we create a symbol and then we do
very final computations over that symbol
but we cannot construct Infinity we
cannot build it we cannot go there from
scratch and uh write down some clever
automaton that produces an Infinity for
you
um I was recently browsing penrose's
book The Road to Reality and I would say
them you know I I don't know that much
about physics but the chapters were
really interesting you know they're
talking about surfaces and manifolds and
symmetries and fiber bundles and gauges
and ways wave functions calculus Matrix
Theory and even computation I mean
almost all of the discussion was on
mathematical modeling at different
levels of description or emergence if
you will and in machine learning and AI
We Are Forever challenged by trying to
get machines to model physical reality
at different levels of description using
an interoperable set of tools so it
seems increasingly true that we need
machines that can learn descriptions and
Concepts at multiple levels if we're
ever going to have AGI capable of
understanding the world and learning
novel semantic models all of machine
learning models today work by chopping
up a euclidean space into what is
effectively a locality sensitive lookup
table very big one and we need agis that
can go far beyond this it's got to be
able to learn novel geometries Beyond
even what humans could have come up with
and the ability to reason topologically
and algebraically over those geometries
something which I think you would agree
is not happening with the current deep
learning systems
but let's start out with the original
geometry first if you read Penrose book
what you find is that this entire
universe is geometric which means it's
made of continuous spaces in which
things are happening
and if we actually look into the world
deeply Quantum mechanic is not a
geometric Theory the geometry only
emerges approximately at the level of
the space-time description
and it seems that geometry is actually
the domain of too many parts to count in
reality all the objects that we describe
as surfaces if we zoom in are made of
discrete Parts like atoms and particles
and so on and these in turn are made out
of things that have a finite resolution
and if we look into our computer
programs we can create stuff that looks
continuous to us but there's nothing
continuous inside of our computer
programs and it turns out that the
Assumption of in of continuity requires
that we partition the space into
infinitely many parts right so now we
are again running against that thing
which girl has shown rounded up gives us
difficult and it's not a big problem in
practice because practice we never need
to do is infinity many things to produce
a computer game with an arbitrary
fidelity
right we can make something that looks
like space
but the space that we think in and so on
is an approximation that our brain is
discovered it's a set of operators that
converge in the limit but the limit
doesn't exist it's just it happens that
when you live in a world that is made of
too many parts to count for almost
everywhere where you look you need to
find these operators that converge in
the limit
and the set of operators that happens to
converge in the limit in a still
computable this is what we call geometry
and to use these uncomputable geometric
approximations for macroscopic physics
like Newtonian mechanics is completely
fine you're just going to compute it up
to a certain digit and then this is good
but it's a problem for foundational
physics because if it turns out that you
cannot take a language that actually
computes Infinities if you cannot
construct as a language then you cannot
write a universe in it right so our
universe is not written in continuous
language but Penrose universe is
so uh does that mean the geometry is
full right we need this to describe the
world of too many parts to count but we
do this via computational approximations
our brain does the same
so let me ask you this then because we
we've come across kind of the Infinities
a couple of times and and I know that
you place an emphasis on constructive
mathematics so of course you and all of
us uh you know except let's say the
existence of potential Infinities you
know algorithms that you can sit there
and just keep calculating for as long as
you want and get kind of more digits but
it's really around actual Infinities
that we seem to be running into uh
problems so let me ask this this first
question here really leading up to some
computational questions which is can the
universe can our actual universe that
we're in right now
be actually infinite and spatial extent
I promise that it can have unboundedness
in the sense that you have a computation
that doesn't stop giving your results
but you cannot take the last result of
such computation and go to the next step
you cannot have a computation that
relies on knowing the last digit of pi
before it goes to the next step so you
don't have an Infinity but Infinity is
about the conclusion of such a function
it means that you actually run this
function to the end and then do
something with the result unboundedness
is different in the sense that it will
always get something new that you didn't
expect that they cannot predict but uh
it's it's just going on and on without
this end and it I think it's completely
conceivable that our universe is in this
class of systems in the sense that it
doesn't end
but uh it doesn't mean that there is
anything that gives you the result of an
infinite computation because if it that
was the case then it could not be
expressed in any language
it also means if something cannot be
expressed in any language that you
cannot actually properly think about it
because when you think you need to think
in some kind of language not in English
but in some kind of language of sort or
in a mathematical language that doesn't
have contradictions and what Gooden has
shown is that the language that you hope
to reason in about infinities
breaks that it has contradictions in it
that at some point it blows blows itself
apart though the languages that we can
build are only those in which we have to
assume that Infinities cannot be built
so Infinity in this sense is meaningless
because we cannot make it in any kind of
language
so the thing is though I'm not limiting
what the universe is capable of based on
human you know mental and linguistic
limitations or even mathematical
limitations like I'm I'm asking you if
it's possible for this universe that
we're in to optically be right now
actually infinite in spatial extent
the thing is that you try to make a
reference to something that you cannot
observe that cannot conceive of other
than making a model in some kind of
language
and to have that model make sense the
language needs to work but otherwise you
are just maybe in some kind of
delusional thing and we can construct
delusional things we can construct
languages that have backs that you
cannot see but if you use a language
that has bugs in it that we cannot see
and we cannot repair them then this
means that the stuff that we Express in
the language is not meaningful right we
have to use a different language that
has maybe the same expressive power but
doesn't have these backs and now if you
try to think about the universe in the
language that allows you to imagine that
the universe is literally infinite
rather than very very big and much
bigger than you can imagine and not
ending which is practice for all means
and purposes almost the same thing right
then if you do this other thing then
your thought doesn't mean anything
so it's basically you cannot properly
express the idea in your own mind
without running into contradictions that
the universe is infinited infinite in
the sense that such a universe could
exist
okay that's the issue I basically I I
cannot think that the universe is
infinite I cannot express this that's my
issue fine so you're basically saying
that the the you know English that I use
just a minute or so ago just as uh you
know not coherent or not conceivable
there's just you know it's not something
the underlying thing we had the English
right English is not designed to be
coherent it's designed to be
disambiguating it's designed to be
unprincipled to allow us to express
things legally and not break but if you
think really really deeply and really
exactly then the question is what kind
of model is your mind building at which
point is that just some kind of noisy
nebulance that you are pointing at
without actually decomposing it in
anything that would make sense okay and
so the lack of of really the ability to
conceive or for you know actual
Infinities to antically exist in some
sense you know if we just deny all that
so we're really just stuck with all
right we've got Phi finite everything
discrete everything there's no such
thing as a Continuum you know there's no
such thing as as actual infinite spatial
extent
Etc that's really the world that you're
proposing here right that everything is
constructed from at the end of the day
finite discrete you know kind of kind of
elements
um so if we you again imagine your mind
is a library of functions in a way and
these functions are doing jobs and on
the outside of the box you write down
what these functions are doing and you
construct a box that this in this box
there is a Infinity between for instance
a Continuum between two points and then
you open up the box and look at what's
actually inside of the box and you
realize it's just a lot of small steps
and it's designed in such a way that you
can if you want to have more steps it's
going to give you more steps if you zoom
in right and it's totally doing
apparently what's written down on the
box but if you look very closely realize
oh no the thing that is written down on
the box that you have written down on
the book cannot actually be in there you
can prove that you cannot be in there it
must be something else that's in there
that is doing most of the work of what
you've written down so what you should
actually be doing I think if you are
interested in housing actually work
right on the box what it's actually
doing
which means it's going to subdivide or
any interval if there's any resolution
you want as long as you can afford it
okay one one mystery if you will uh for
me and I'm hoping can help me understand
this is that all of the standard
standard models for physics right that
we have today
um they do have in them these continuous
you know for example symmetries that uh
rotational symmetry or or things like
that they're built off of of positing
continuums with with continuous waves
and you know lots of lots of
continuities and Infinities at least in
the the mathematical descriptions and I
think you would based on quantum
mechanics right right yeah and I think
based on what you've been saying you
would say that those are those are
artifacts or properties of our of our
mathematical descriptions of reality but
they're not actually extant you know in
reality and my mystery there is why do
those those continuous and and
mathematical maybe flawed and
inconsistent with Infinities all over
the place descriptions works so well for
for describing phenomenon at different
levels if everything at the end of the
day you know if we just looked at high
enough energy and small enough
resolution we'd see kind of the the uh
the grid and you know all the discrete
effects and rotationing happening kind
of in little tiny tiny infinite you know
tiny very small but not infinitesimal
degrees you know why does all this
continuous Infinity based mathematics
work so well what is the explanation for
the unreasonable effectiveness of that
kind of mathematics
uh the easiest answer is that the world
in which we lived in is made of
extremely small parts and we could not
exist if that world was not made of that
many small parts so for instance you
want to have a momentum for particles
that are almost continuous so you can
address the space with high resolution
because the momentum is what tells you
where information comes from in the
universe basically the direction of
where from which information reaches you
and so on if that would be very coarse
then the complexity that you could build
would probably be found or and we
consist of so many parts when you look
down it's uncountably many for all
practical purposes so the mathematics
that we need to describe the world that
we are in that we need to model are
mostly not in the realm of countable
numbers the countable numbers only play
a role pin V are looking at very few
macroscopic sinks as soon as we leave
this domain of a few apples on our table
we almost instantly drop in this round
where we just need to switch to a
continuous description of things
and this is completely fine for most of
our history when we did physics we never
zoomed in that heart and even now when
we verily need to zoom at the level
where the plank length matters and the
resolution of the universe becomes
visible and it's of course not some
euclidean letters some grid that you can
see it's just that at this level to no
longer have space
um I wanted to move matters back over to
some of the happenings in the you know
the world of large language models and
and deep learning and so on and first
quick fire question and I I honestly
you're a bit of an enigma to me Joshua
because obviously um I I've read some of
your research and and you seem like a
hybrid guy to me you're very you know
Ben getzel very well for example but
you're also hugely into the hype train
on on the connectionism and you uh you
know for example you criticize Gary
Marcus's article so the first question
is are you a symbolist or a
connectionist I'm neither the thing is
that I hate deep learning is the best of
us it's just a deep learning is ugly
it's brutalist it's a few very simple
algorithms that are blown up to the max
but I cannot prove that these algorithms
do not converge to what we want them to
converge to
right it's it's maybe not elegant but it
works and the solution to uh problems
with deep learning so far has always
been to use more deep learning not less
uh so what
um upsets me about Gary Marcus argument
is not that I'm not sympathetic to what
he's trying to push at I like to build
models that are more elegant more sparse
and so on but uh in in the past all
these uh elegant virus models have been
left in the Dust by just using more deep
learning
and we can also see when we zoom out a
little bit that there is not an obvious
limit to deep learning itself Because
deep learning is not just three
algorithms deep learning is a
programming Paradigm it's differentiable
programming basically means that you
express everything with a proximately
continuous numbers and you use
algorithms that converge a business
certain ranges and uh when it doesn't
converge then you just tweak it and
you'd introduce a different architecture
which is some kind of
um discrete operations that you do on
these continuous numbers and so on if
you just patch it when you write your
program slightly differently and you can
automate the search for the program and
the people who do deep learning are not
also dogs in the sense that they say oh
my God symbolic structures are not
allowed I cannot use a python script in
here rather than uh just a tensorflow
this is not what's happening it's also
not that they are constrained to any
kind of thing they will use whatever is
working and what we see is that the end
to entrance systems are growing more and
more powerful and rather than sitting
there by hand and tinkering and finding
a solution we can just use a system that
is tinkering automatically through a
dramatically larger space than we would
ever be able to explore by trying all
sorts of algorithms so when we look at
Gary Marcus articles like this deep
learning is hitting a wall and so on and
you look what he's actually giving us
arguments the arguments are not very
good he gives us an example the net heck
challenge network is a game which is in
very large Horizon because you basically
have only one lie you need to explore a
very deep Labyrinth you need to plan
pretty far ahead with what you're doing
and so it's something that is difficult
to discover this right solution with a
deep learning model that has no prior
ideas about what it's doing because it
takes us very very long until you get
the necessary feedback to learn about
your actions and people are relatively
good at learning this because they have
so many the ideas about what the
situation is that they're in there's so
many priors from our world interaction
and from other games that we have played
that we can bring to the tasks so the
current winner of this is a symbolic
solution
and this symbolic solution to carry
Marcus gives us a proof that symbolic
methods are still ahead of deep learning
things in a single case right not like
he has a big array of tasks where they
are superior it's just two students who
have written a program that is made of
lots and lots of events this is just a
big hack this is not some symbolic
learning algorithm that does something
novel hybrid or whatever no this is test
the script and people is Gary Marcus
there is a proposing oh my God deep
learning models are limited and we need
to replace them with more Scripts
this is not a good argument
yeah so so I think maybe and look I I
get that there are these kind of two
competing camps and they maybe go after
each other with some no they don't this
is only on Twitter there is there are no
competing camps it's uh yandikun is not
also dogs in the sense that he believed
you need to use this algorithm all the
other arguments are impure and plot
is the build systems that work and if
one of his people comes up is something
that works better than what he came up
with he probably uh praise him for that
and let him go on
yeah sure but there's absolutely however
there is um you know there is uh let's
say momentum and Hardware lotteries and
and paradigms that kind of reinforce
themselves and to an extent they can
strangle off you know resources that
maybe we like we shouldn't be investing
all our eggs in one basket we shouldn't
be pouring you know the 99 of research
funding necessarily down down deep
learning and I think that's kind of the
problem that that these paradigms cause
but I want to get back to something you
said which is it it's a good point it's
I think it's an important point I think
that in absolute terms the other
approaches get more money than they did
before it's not that we have a funding
stop as we had at some point of research
funding stop for neural networks in
Marvin Minsky wrote a book where he
thought he had proven that the neural
networks cannot converge over multiple
layers okay press up front cannot turn
xor and so on right Minsky was wrong
people found a way around this but at
this time there was so little funding
that this kind of method and at the
moment if you want to do something that
has Ai and headline the chance that you
get it funded well what Paradigm you're
doing is greater than ever so the
absolute amount of fence that goes into
any kind of Paradigm that you want to
work on is greater than ever and the
reason why the majority of funds goes
into very few paradigms is because these
are the things that work in industrial
applications
there is no other algorithm that is able
to learn from scratch Hall to translate
between arbitrary languages and generate
stories and draw pretty pictures for you
this is the only game in town at the
moment the only class of algorithm that
converges over all these many domains
and people are looking for better
Alternatives and yes we are in a bubble
because of course they are looking
mostly where things already were that
you have Hardware that works you have
libraries that work and so on it's hard
to get out of that but that is true and
it's always good to push for
Alternatives and so on but I don't think
that we should be in a panic and say oh
my God there is something politically
wrong I suspect that by and large the
forces of the markets and the forces of
the academic researchers that want to
explore alternatives are pushing in the
right direction already
yeah I mean fair enough uh and you know
you could be right and there may not be
that much of an imbalance but I want to
get back to One technical thing you said
um yes I I it it seems apparent that
let's say what deep learning is doing is
this this differentiable program search
if you will and a question I have about
that is if we imagine the space of of
all possible programs
um that you know requiring that we're
doing a differentiable search is
certainly going to skew that sample
space it may even cut off uh programs
um in that space that can't be
discovered easily by by differentiable
search so I'm wondering doesn't that
leave open the possibility that other
algorithms that are more discreet in
nature say evolutionary algorithms or
discrete program search or whatever they
may have access to a different Subspace
of the space of all all programs that
aren't easily accessible by
differentiable
paradigms is that true
now the question is how did you find it
how did you find this algorithm is to
manipulate the discrete things they
agree that when you have a perceptual
model that is um modeling everything
this chains or sums over real numbers
and if you know the attributes thrown in
he would get characteristic artifact for
instance in the generative models you
often have the problem then you try to
Model A person with glasses or without
glasses that because the model thinks
that these features are somewhat
continuous you often run into the
situation to get areas in the generative
model where the glasses are half
materialized and looks always very weird
and you have these strange things where
reality has a discontinuity but your
model has permissible states where uh
you are in the smack in the middle of
the discontinuity and you try to
generate something that cannot exist if
you want your model to be structured in
such a way ideally that every model
configuration corresponds to a world
configuration and this is not naturally
the case because many of the deep
learning models and what the Deep
learning models is you train them harder
typically tend to do is that they
decrease these intermissible areas until
you are very unlikely to end up in them
and it's probably possible to get them
to implement filters and all sorts of
tricks but what you can also do is you
can combine this with some kind of
discrete machine and then what you do is
you learn how to use this so this deep
Learning Network it's not interacting
with the world directly but it learns
how to use an architecture that does
that
so for instance instead of training a
neural network to do numerical
calculations you can train it to use a
numerical calculator
and in this way it can become very
sparse again right so there's not an
obvious limit to that I can see where I
can prove to the Deep learning people oh
here is where you should stop deep
learning because they can just combine
their deep learning approach with other
approaches and use the Deep Learning
System to remote control this and it
turns out when we reason and so on even
when we do discrete recently that the
steps that we assemble it to each other
are heuristics that require some kind of
probabilistic element right so when we
form a saw at it when the sword is made
of very discrete elements the search for
that sort is some kind of deep learning
process that is happening right and when
we make the pro we do this we emulate
the discrete reasoning but of course we
can't combine this and we can get a
neural network to learn how to perform
the discrete operations
there's a certain thing that I would
like to see which is something like a
more worse language of thought
when we are looking at Deep learning
models there's a phenomenon that people
are sometimes observing which they call
rocking that is um you train the model
and your model gets better and better
and then it overfits which means it gets
very good at the training data but it
gets very bad on the real world I'd
think that it hasn't seen before like a
person on psychedelics was able to
explain everything in the past but is no
longer able to perform well in the
future because they are overfitting they
basically fit the curve too closely to
the data that I've seen
and there are many tricks in deep
learning to go around this overfitting
to make sure that this doesn't happen
and people try to avoid it and then what
they discovered is when you take this
overfit model you train it more and more
and more and more at some point it
sometimes clicks and it gets much better
than ever before
and there's the question if the uh if
there's something that we're doing wrong
then deep learning for instance
um then you will think about how people
learn they learn very different from
gpt3
people first learn by pointing at stuff
at things that are relevant to them that
they can eat that they convert that
convert them or that they find Pleasant
and so on they that they can feel that
they can that they have contrast on it
that are Salient to them and so you
start out with learning these semantics
based on the saliency and relevance that
you have and then when you learn
language you learn basic syntax how to
put things together and the long tail of
the syntax you learn style how to
express things as nuance and so on and
this gpt3 it's the opposite you first
learn style
right and then you learn syntax as the
regularities in the style and the
semantics is the long tail of that
and you to make that happen you need to
learn much much more you need to have
more training data and so on maybe
there's a way in which we can reverse
the order and basically get it to start
out with relevance to build a curriculum
where you first get very fast
regularities where the world clicks into
place and you always make sure that you
can handle it with very limited
resources and only see the style and the
United States and the nuances is still
far extensions of these very sparse
concise models that have very big
predictive power
yeah I mean on on that I I mean the
groking paper was very interesting and a
lot a lot of these large language model
fans always cite that very very quickly
when you have a conversation with them
but um there is a problem with machine
learning in general which is that there
is as you said there's a spectrum of
correlations and almost all of them are
spurious and on on one side of that
Spectrum you have the idealized features
you actually want it to learn which will
generalize after distribution and then
of course if you go down that Spectrum
you you pick up on all sorts of
um very spurious correlations that just
happen to generalize very well and if
you tell the models not to use those
viewers correlations the the performance
of the model will go down but I want to
just move a little bit over to yazaman's
resegi the asaman rosegi's paper
um I don't know whether you saw that but
she showed that the performance of large
language models for arithmetic tasks are
linearly correlated to the term
frequency in the training Corpus
suggesting that they are memorizing the
data set which presumably you would
agree with and Google has recently
released this 540 billion parameter
language model called Palm which
interestingly does extremely well on for
example some of the Google big bench
tasks such as the conceptual
combinations task which is one of them
which tests for compositionality which
we'll talk about in a minute but um you
know compositionalities is when you can
take constituents from The Prompt and
compose them together to form the answer
now it's tempting to jump to the
conclusion that these models are
starting to magically reason at scale
along the lines that you are just
discussing but I still think there's
plenty of opportunities for shortcut
learning you know by which I mean these
spurious correlations given the brittle
interface of an auto regressive GPT
style language model with these human
designed benchmarks would you agree with
that yeah
uh when I started my own career in
computer science in the 90s I was in New
Zealand and the Prof in bitten realized
that I was ward in class so he took me
out of the class and uh in his lab and
he gave me the task to discover
grammatical structure and an unknown
language from scratch
and left me pretty much to my own
devices on how to do this so the unknown
language I picked was English was just
unknown to the computer but it was the
easiest one to get a corpus for and they
gave me the largest computer they had it
has two gigabytes of RAM and they did
in-memory compression with c and so on
and tried to do statistics and I quickly
realized engram statistics don't work
because of too many words in between so
unlike Vision tasks where Point Nets
have a useful prior by thinking that
adjacent pixels also relate to
symbiantically related information right
so adjacency in images is a very good
predictor for thematic relatedness it
doesn't really work in NLP though the
Transformer was discovered in natural
language processing for that reason
because you cannot use direct adjacency
very well and so I realized I cannot use
n grams which depend on Direct adjacency
between birds and so I first of all use
ordered pairs of words
and try to find correlations between
Pairs and then find a mutual information
tree that would give me the best
prediction over the structure of the the
sentence for all the sentences that I
would have in my Fortress and indeed
this correlates with structure and I
realized this is going to not just give
me grammar but it's also also going to
give me semantics if I can more deep uh
statistics but I will need something not
just for ordered pairs but I need to
have something like force order models
but to do the statistics even in memory
it is clever in memory compression and
many tricks that I did I could not do
four statistics on this so uh what I
realized I had to do was that I do
multiple passes and at first I discard
almost all the information I only pick
out the most Salient things
and then my time was over in the slab
and I went back to Germany and never
revisit this area of research again but
what I had realized is to make progress
and need to make Statistics over what I
need to make the statistics over
and the Very principled base I need to
learn what I have to learn
and they didn't pay attention to this
domain at all and also missed the 2017
Transformer paper and its relevance it
was only when gpt2 came out that I
realized oh my God they did this they
did Statistics over the statistics and
it's it's still not the uh right
solution I think that's not Avail which
our brain is doing it it's some Brute
Force shortcut where for instance the
individual attention heads are not
correlated with each other but the
reality they are we have this in reality
our the tension Nets are integrated into
one model of what's going on
and it's not that we have an attention
Network on every delay every layer that
just pays attention to what's happening
in the lower layer right it's it's much
more clever in our own mind and this
thing is active we single out things in
reality research which book we need to
take out of the Shelf to update our
working memory context so we are able to
interpret the current sentence that we
don't understand and so we always go for
the agency when we read something that
doesn't make sense at least my my mind
works like this I discard it I will uh
will not stop until it makes sense or I
will have to go to some preliminary I
will not accept some kind of vague
statistical approximation of what I read
and keep this as an intermediary stage
in my mind and help with the hope that
eventually converges right so it's it's
a completely different learning Paradigm
when we teach our children arithmetic
it's not that we show them lots of very
long Mass textbooks and hope that
initially that will not make any sense
to them but as they reread them again
and again with many samples eventually
it will click and they will call words
on arithmetic no this is not how it
works his drive has given them extremely
simple things and say in these extremely
simple things the structure that you can
fully understand now go and find the
structure that you fully understand once
you've done it you make this a little
bit more complicated for you right this
this is probably the Paradigm that we
could be exploring
I know but the problem is it's
incredibly deceptive when you have
something which appears intelligence and
of course the um the boundary of our
perception of intelligence is is a
receding one but I wanted to just get on
to there are some incredible generative
uh visual models like Dali and
um you know the Disco diffusion so these
models I think are going to
revolutionize the creative profession
I've been playing with disco diffusion
all day today I've already ordered some
prints to go on my wall it's incredible
so yeah the two obvious settings where
large language models
um you know might be successful
um are coding and information retrieval
in in my opinion but let's take pause
for thought right so I've played with
codex
and I'm resolutely sure that I wouldn't
want to use it
um I think code and knowledge are a
different ball game to Art which I think
will be amazing with codex there's an
impedance mismatch between the process
of generating the code and then
debugging and running the code which is
euphemistically been framed as prompt
engineering or another term which I've
just invented uh retrospective
development I think it's easier to start
again from scratch than fix broken code
from a large language model
um I mean this is quite interesting at
Google it already takes months to get
any code checked into their mono repo
because it's basically a bureaucracy
because they needed to um you know to
have gatekeeping after they decided to
use a mono repo so could you imagine how
much bureaucracy there'd be if they
allow people to start checking in code
which was you know generated from an
algorithm so anyway I think there's an
exciting possible future for using these
systems for information retrieval you
know rather than the the way that we
kind of go through and prune the results
on on a Google search these models might
just answer directly but I hasten to
think what that search UI would look
like you know would its output be
sclerotic or unadaptable would it be
relevant to the query that I that I put
in would its output even be true
um perhaps it will ask you to select
what kind of Truth you were looking for
so you know do you think these models
would vitiate or spoil our society or do
you think they would actually enrich it
they're very hard to say I think that
from some perspective our society is
already maximally spoiled
that humans as they live today are
basically Locus with opposable stamps
this is not going to go on forever this
technological Society here are it seems
to me on some kind of Titanic that is
going to hit the iceberg no matter what
and what basically should make us
content is that the Titanic was the only
place in the universe that has internet
and we are born on it and we wouldn't
have been born if if there was no
Titanic we would not have you born in a
sustainable ancestral Society
but so in some sense our society needs
to reinvent itself it's not really
working right now we don't know what the
future is going to look like and if it's
going to be very technological or if
limit certain things
um no idea what's going to happen but uh
if you think about how our current
approaches work if you want to estimate
programming better I suspect that these
tools can help
but they will be much more useful if you
do not have to have this battle between
a machine that doesn't really understand
what you want and instead you have
something that is uh working next to you
it's the deck imagine you were working
for some cooperation and the corporation
introduces some kind of planning tool
that requires to do a two jumps to all
sorts of hopes and it turns out that the
planning tool itself makes you more
productive but it makes work much less
fun
it's so rational to use it and everybody
will hate it but uh by and large it will
be used if it makes people slightly more
productive and everybody will feel there
might be it must be a better solution
something that feels more organic and so
it could be that codex is in this
category that it makes mediocre
programmers much more productive at
producing boilerplate but it's not just
this it's often able to find Solutions
very quickly that you need to use a lot
of stack Overflow before you understand
the new language or before you tease
this new algorithm or part that you want
to understand and so on it's just when
it doesn't probably turn you into a
better programmer if that is your goal
but for your employer maybe they don't
care whether you're a better programmer
they just want you to churn out these
pages of code and then they run this
against the verifier and against the
unit test and then are done go to the
next thing right so maybe it's not that
important but the systems that we would
want what would they look like I think
they need to know what they're doing you
want to have a program that is not just
able to reproduce something very well in
the given context you want to understand
the context as deeply as you do or
better so it needs to understand what
kind of world it's operating in in the
moment and what itself is what is it
that it can do what is that what it
needs to learn still let's see in some
sense you want systems that are sentient
and this sounds like oh my God but it
just means you have a learning system
that's General enough to model in
principle the entire universe and this
is not as outrageous as it sounds
because uh Delhi is already dealing with
two modalities language and images and
we will get to video and we will get to
audio connected and you see them early
steps in this Direction with the
socratic model paper for instance so I
think that's almost inevitable that this
generality will happen and you will have
to add a system to work in real time so
it can Discover It depth
I think I think
there's something really magic though
about the um the creative process here
and also um The Prompt engineering is
another thing we we can talk about but
um Kenneth Stanley once made this thing
called pick breeder and you could
essentially distribute the selection of
these images created with cppn's
compositional pattern producing networks
yeah and you would just get these
beautiful images they were they were so
incredibly Pro you know incredibly and
diverse and interesting so it's not that
the um algorithms were intelligent there
is something magic about the
externalized process and what's really
interesting about these models like Dali
for example is that creativity has been
distilled down to a raw idea in your
head right so for example
um I might decide to mix the style of
two artists and combine them with a new
subject and I want a black cat in front
of Royal Holloway University and the
style of cyberpunk I've been doing that
all day and the technical process is now
done for you the only limit is your
imagination so just like Kenneth
Stanley's picture reader creativity
itself has now become this Uber
efficient and externalized process I
think it's unreal but the thing is like
the reason I never thought gpt3 was
intelligent is because it can't be used
non-interactively the magic must happen
um when it's used by humans
interactively
but you can uh basically build a machine
that is generating problems for GPT
Suite so in principle you can build a
robot that has a vision to text module
and that is used to prompt gpt3 into
generating a story about a robot who
sees these things and interacts with
them and then you take the output of the
generative model and translate this
using a text to motor module and in this
way you close the loop and while this uh
I just used it as a thought experiment
to think about limitations of embodiment
for such systems uh they can is
essentially doing that right so somebody
has made this happen and it even with a
language model it works to some degree
and we know that we don't want to do
this with natural language because
natural language is a crutch this
systems make up for this by you just
using more natural language pasta than
people could use it but there is some
language of thought that we are using
that is not learned but discovered by
our own mind that we Converge on it is
much more efficient and this language of
thought seems to be able to bottom out
and perceptual distributed
representations that are unprincipled
like these neural networks are in a
sense I'm principle so they don't break
then there is something that is vague
and ambiguous and has small
contradictions in it but at some level
it also is able to emulate very
principal logic very well and becomes
very sparse and very powerful in
expressing things concisely and this
very precise language of sort is I don't
so don't see it in our models what Delhi
is doing is Delhi 2 is that it combines
the language model and division model
using embedding spaces and these
embedding spaces basically project all
the concepts into some high dimensional
manifold and find similarities between
them
and Gary Marcos points out that there is
an issue with compositionality in this
right so you need to find the semantic
structure of a sentence that is made of
a hierarchy of Concepts and this is easy
to do with the grammar and it's much
harder to do this with a deep Learning
System that needs to discover this in a
way and structure this space in the
right way it's not impossible so when
Gary Market says these models cannot do
this and cannot learn it he is probably
wrong but uh he I think he is right in
the sense that this is something that's
much much harder for the current
approaches they need dramatic training
data than the human being and the
algorithms are not doing this naturally
so there are probably ways in which we
could make this happen much more
elegantly and quickly a converged for
instance on models for arithmetic
that's right I mean I remember I read a
really good uh Twitter thread I think it
was by Raphael miliere you know about
compositionality of these large
generative Vision models because usually
compositionality is referred to in
respect of language models you know and
there's this um uh I think Raphael said
that the assessment of the claim is
Complicated by the fact that people
differ in their understanding of of what
compositionality means but if language
is is compositional as you say and
thought is language like as argued by
the proponents of this language of
thought hypothesis I think Raphael said
that he thought language itself um you
know should be compositional in a
similar sense and perhaps by extension
visual imagery should be compositional
so I think Gary was arguing in a
nutshell that it's hard to go from the
image or let's say the utterance if it's
NLP to the structure or the grammar or
the constituents it's much easier to go
the other way around would you agree
and the issue is that language of sort
is executable and natural language is
not
right the execute natural language by
translating it into our mind in
something that we can execute
and use a reason about code you might
use natural language to support your
reasoning but the code that you build in
your mind is filled in some kind of
abstract syntax tree that you can
actually execute in your mind to some
degree and then you get a sense of the
output right so you entrain your own
brain with an executable structure
and this executable structure has
properties that are quite similar to the
ones that the compiler has in your
computer right so you can anticipate
what the compiler is going to do with
your code go not going to do this with
all the depths that your compiler do it
you might still have to run your code
but you will find when you want to
experience programmer your stuff will
usually run
right so uh our language of thought can
do this it can execute stuff and it's
not just some machine neural network
that guesses but the outcome is going to
be and this rate some of the time but uh
it gets pretty good at figuring this out
this means that it has to build this
computer a compositional structure that
has some verifiable properties and we
observe ourselves operating on this
verification process right when we do
introspection for every program we
observe ourselves how we direct our
attention on making proofs and this
attentional algorithm that works in real
time
that is making changes on your mental
models and then predicts the outcome of
these changes and look Compares this
with what your mental computations give
you and then fixes your models of how
your own thinking process in this domain
works and so on like you can observe
yourself doing that and uh it's nothing
where I would say a given approach or
the given approaches that we have will
never get there but there seem to be
ways in which we have just barely
scratched the surface and what you need
to be doing to make these models sample
efficient and sparse and more adequate
to what domains you're interested in
cool okay well um I mean just to finish
like the discussion about the open AI
stuff I mean I agree with the
prognosticators and I do think that
these large language models and these
visual generative models will be
revolutionary for some domains but
um
you know I think you really need to have
a human guiding the creative process
which is a huge limitation but I think
it could also potentially hint at what
intelligence actually is right I think
intelligence might be this externalized
process in a cybernetic sense if you
like this idea of Intelligence being
fully embedded in an algorithm in a
single agent might be might be the wrong
way to think about it
I think that humans by knowledge are
very confused very often you need a
human to guide the human right and uh
then you ask yourself if you do this
recursively does the society know where
it's going or is this at some level
confusion at all levels that is
balancing each other
so there seem to be very few people with
a plan right now and it's quite apparent
when you see that in the Sciences we see
this in politics we did it's an art and
third feature it is that humans have a
higher degree of sentience but by and
large very few people have a principle
plan on how to build sustainable
harmonic world and if you set an AI
system to this task it might make more
progress on it it's just that Dali is
not operating in real time on the
universe that is entangled first and
neither is gpt3 both of them are in some
sense fancy autocomplete algorithms
but this uh fancy autocomplete is able
to do a auto completing the driver far
beyond the auto computation abilities of
humans in almost every context and so I
don't see Italy yet as hard it's a very
strange sense when uh someone that open
AI let me throw trumps at Dali 2 and I
got images back I had a sense of
ownership I had the sense that I was
doing that even though it was clearly
doing skills using skills that I didn't
have and I suppose that you had the same
impression when you were generating
things with your diffusion model that
you're going to put up on your walls
right you did that using this amazing
tool that was empowering you to think
that you otherwise never could do but
you are the creative Nexus and to make
an artist a digital artist you would
need to create an autonomous creative
Nexus in a way a creative entity
something that reflects on the world
because art is about capturing conscious
States so we would need to build a
system that has a story about itself and
that is reacting to its own interaction
festival and the thing wouldn't need to
be human it would need to be consistent
something that is an intelligent entity
that is creatively interacting with the
world I think we could totally build an
AI artist franchise right now that would
have a huge following but what it need
to have is an identity that is not fake
that is actually built from its
interactions with the world in real time
well I think we've got a lovely segue
there because
you you said that um you know artist art
is about representing our conscious
States
um in a way I disagree with because you
could say well it's very reductionist
I've just put I've just put a prompt in
there and I've created art well I think
it I think it is our but how much of a
representation of my conscious state is
it I think Douglas hofstatter would say
it wasn't but over over to the matter of
Consciousness because we're a bit low on
time I mean you you said actually that
you've spent much of your life thinking
about what Consciousness is and um you
said that you you thought it was very
mysterious but you now think that it's a
riddle that can be uh solved right so on
your recent Theory of Everything
interview with Donald Hoffman actually
you said that it was virtual not a
physical thing that brains are
mechanistic and that the elements of
Consciousness are magical somehow but
you said it had an a causal structure
but not the way physics is built but it
was a story which the physical system
tells to itself you said that the
organism is a coherent and consistent
pattern
which is State Building at least at some
level of analysis and that Consciousness
allows organisms to coordinate their
cells to succeed in their niches and
then you spoke of information processing
over cells now what model of I should
say like what measure of Consciousness
do you think you most align with
and it is only once you read that offers
a measure of Consciousness and there's
this integrated information Theory
whereas you actually put a number on it
and it's not clear what that number
means
right it's uh it's not that there's some
kind of scalar that measures this and
and people we think of Consciousness as
something that is more qualitative than
quantitative either somebody is
conscious or somebody is unconscious and
then you are conscious you can have a
lack of Acuity you can be adults in your
brain and you can be drifting in and out
of Consciousness but uh it's still a
qualitative thing of whether you have
that or not and this qualitative thing
seems to be simple
probably much simpler that people expect
it to be
the right thing might be perception
and Consciousness is on top of
perception is a certain way to deal with
our attention so I think a very
important aspect of Consciousness is
reflexive attention that we notice
ourselves attending to something and we
reflect on that and integrate this in
our model
the conundrum is understanding
Consciousness if you go right into the
history of everything striking is
lightness and many others leibniz says
this idea of imagine you could have a
Mill and this this is your mind and this
the mill is made of lots of mechanical
parts and somehow the thing is feeling
and perceiving things and we blow the
middle up so large that we can walk into
bit or if we would today they may zoom
into it until you see all the parts and
we just do these pushing and folding
parts and nothing of them can ever
explain a perception or a Feeling
and it's just uh it's a very strong
intuition that also drives the Chinese
room and many that other thinkers will
uh get attracted to this and it seems
pretty obvious that these mechanical
phenomena are insufficient to explain
what's going on it's not an obvious
connection so people become dualists
they're somehow are two completely
separate domains and I think in a way
this dualism is correct but not in the
sense that the mental states are
ontologically existing
they are exist as if
there is no argument that there is only
this connection of cells in this
collection of cells is acting in a
coherent way which means you can
compress it you can model it using a
very low dimensionals much circular
function then look at all the cells in
general and the organism is only
approximating this function but what
makes the organism more powerful than
the collection of cells is exactly that
function the structure that we project
into it and the interesting thing is
that by the information processing
within the organism the organism can
discover that function by itself and use
it to drive its own behavior
so while the organism is not a person
it's not even an organism it is very
useful for the organism to behave it if
it was an organism and also to have an
idea what it would be like to be a
person that interacts for instance with
the social world
so it creates a simulation of that and
it's often not even a simulation that's
often just a symbol aquam that's what
makes it a causal the difference between
a simulation and the reality is that the
simulation is modeling some aspects of
the Dynamics of a domain on a different
causal substrate on the different
quarter footing so you have a computer
game in which you can shoot a gun but
there is no proper physics in the game
that would uh
recreate what's happened in the real
world when you shoot the gun right it's
dead it is using a different causal
structure of your software program to
give you something that gives you good
enough Dynamics so you can interact with
the bolt and experience this course of
structures you can make a different
decision you make different move in the
game and as a result the game behaves as
if you would expect it because it's
imitating the same fossil structure
using this different substrate in the
symbolism because we don't have the
causal structure like a movie doesn't
have causal structure it only gives you
a sequence of observables and our own
mental model of ourselves is a mixture
of simulation and Similac from
so like we sometimes create a sequence
without cost of structure it looks like
it does this thing magically and
sometimes we have a causal model but
this quarter model is not the real deal
it's just this simplified geometric
simulation of how the world works at
game engine that our brain is producing
to anticipate what happens in the
physical world
yeah so that that very strongly
resonates with me in another uh another
person I very much respect his opinion
resonates with me regarding
Consciousness is Carl friston and uh you
know I'm not sure how much you're
familiar with his his free energy
principle and and his thoughts on uh
Consciousness but I'd like to put
forward to you one of his more recent
um definitions if you will or proposals
to explain Consciousness and I get your
opinion on it this is from his 2018
article
titled am I self-conscious or does
self-organization entail
self-consciousness and what he says here
is the proposal on offer here is that
the Mind comes into being when
self-evidencing has a temporal thickness
or counter factual depth which grounds
inferences about the consequences of my
action on this view Consciousness is
nothing more than inference about my
future namely the self-evidencing
consequences of what I could do
does that align pretty closely with your
your view
no I don't think it's sufficient and
also don't think it's necessary
I like for instance idea but most of the
free energy principle comes down to
predictive coding which is in some sense
a radically tested with gpg3 gbt3 is uh
trained in some sense entirely on
predictive coding it's only trying to
predict the future from the past
and the future is the next token based
on the token set it has seen so far in
gptv magically tries how far you can go
with this and you can go very far
but uh you will need waffle wall samples
than an organism does
so there are players in us that go
beyond predictive coding maybe the
converge towards this over many
generations in The evolutionary process
so I don't think it's a stupid idea that
Corporation proposes but uh we are born
this additional loss functions that let
us converge much much faster on
something that is useful to the organism
and uh if we think about Consciousness
he has a point about agency in there
agency means that you have a controller
that is able to control the future
took me some while to understand this
but when I grew up we talked about BDI
agents and they seem to be quite
complicated and convoluted to put a lot
of code there to make a PDI agent but
there is beliefs desires and intentions
and so on but uh if we think about what
actually is a minimal agent
it's almost out is not a minimal age and
the subject has not agency it doesn't
want anything it just acts on the
present frame by doing the obvious thing
but imagine that you give the thermostat
the ability to integrate the expected
temperature differentiates that
differences over the future when it does
X now or why now or does it a moment
later right so suddenly you have a
branching reality and in this branching
reality you can make decisions and you
will have preferences based on this
integrated expected reward right so just
by giving the thermostat the ability to
model the future you turn it into an
agent
this is sufficient and if you make this
motive deeper and deeper it's going to
get better and better at it and at a
certain depth the summer start is going
to discover itself it's the square and
discover the idiosyncrasies of its
sensors and notice that the sensor
operates differently when it's closer to
the heating element and so on and so on
right so it becomes aware of how it
functions it might even become aware of
the way in which it's modeling and
reasoning process works and to improve
it or to account for the its
inefficiencies in certain ways and this
is also what we do with our own cell but
this model of the self is not identical
to our Consciousness our Consciousness
is a feeling of what it's like in the
moment it's the experience often now
it's there is an experience of a
perspective that we are having right and
this is what's absent in the description
of first and he is missing the core
point of what for what it means for some
to be conscious doesn't mean that it has
a self it doesn't even just mean it is a
first person perspective it means that
it experiences reality
and this is
yeah we we explicitly asked and this
question actually when we talked talked
to him last time and his response there
was that you know this concept of of
feel feel like
um is really something that that would
need to be coded into the generative
model that this you know that this agent
has about the world like it number one
it has to have a generative model as
we've just been discussing it has to be
able to entertain counterfactual you
know possibilities uh for the predictive
coding right and he's saying that these
feel like Concepts would would literally
be encoded in that generative model as
hypotheses that we recognize you know so
so things like I'm I'm feeling pain for
example would be a concept within that
model and he says there's actually
evidence from uh you know treating
patients with chronic pain and this sort
of thing that that's actually exactly
what's happening in the mind that that
the feeling of pain is actually a
concept
that's built in as a slot if you will
into this generative model
I mean
what do you think about that proposal
the semantics of pain are given by the
avoidance
that you don't want to experience the
pain usually
and it could be that you cultivate the
pain and use it to make something
happening on the next level but it
requires that you are then building a
multi-level console structure if you
want to use pain productively some
artists that may be doing but the you
cannot have pain I think without an
action tendency without something that
modulates what you are doing
so your your cognition is embedded into
this engine and to build such an engine
that does it that causally changes how
you operate is not that hard
but when you live inside of such an
engine it feels very strange that there
is something that is happening that
somewhat depends on what you are
thinking but you cannot control it it
controls you it's Upstream from you you
are Downstream from it
and when you get Upstream of your own
pain the pain stops being pain it's
something that is a representation that
you can now control
and we are able to get there but it's
not easy and we are not meant to get
there because it means that we can
immunize ourselves to pain and sacrifice
the organism to our intellectual
interests what's crucial about feelings
when you look at them introspectively is
that feelings are essentially geometric
I don't know if you noticed that so for
instance we know this feelings typically
in our body
and that's because I think that the
feelings play out in a space and the
only space that we have always
instantiated in our mind is the body map
so they're being projected into the
space to make them distinct and when we
look at the semantics of the feeling we
notice that there are Contracting or
expanding or they are light or they're
heavy and so on is this all movement of
Staff in space right it's all geometry
plus valence the stuff that is going to
push your behaviors in a certain
direction
so these are basically the interactions
of uh some deep Learning System
that is producing a continuous geometric
representations and as we perceived from
an analytic engine right it's an
interface between two parts of your mind
between the analytic attention control
that is reflecting on the operations
that your mind is doing while it's
optimizing its attention and the
underlying system that represents the
state of the organism and tells where
you should be going
and makes this visible to you with this
A system that is not able to speak to
you uses geometry and this is the
geometrical features this is what we
call feelings
so that's a very interesting connection
and I think uh I think Jeff Hawkins of
uh you know nemento would be would be
quite interested in in that as well
because uh some of what he what he
discussed with us was that
um in his view the evolution of of let's
say abstract thinking and whatnot
actually came from systems that evolved
to operate in just a simple
three-dimensional kind of motion and
that eventually those were were
reutilized by by you know the
evolutionary process to start engaging
in abstract thinking which he views is
is movement through through an abstract
space and so I think there's a lot of
connection here to what you're saying
about feeling which is that again you
know in a sense in a sense our mind is
reutilized this this three three plus
one B you know movement mapping
capability that it needed in order to
survive in a three plus one b
um you know environment physical
environment and it's reutilized those
for mapping feelings it's reutilized
them for mapping to abstract thinking is
like a form of motion in in an abstract
space is that a fair connection
yeah yes but I don't think that it's
because it's borrowed from the world in
which we interact but because of the
this is the only game in town it's the
only mathematics that can deal with
multi-dimensional numbers
right so when we talk about spaces we
actually talk about multi-dimensional
numbers
about things that are not just the
scalar in a single Dimension but the
features that are related and sometimes
you can take these features that you
measure continuously because they have
too many steps for meaningful they
discretize them
out right so what you do is you
sometimes discover that you can rotate
something and this is when you get a
space in a sense as we have a space to
which we are moving and these spaces
which you can rotate things only exist
in 2D and 4D and 80.
and uh so the geometry that we're
talking about is constrained two certain
mathematical paradigms which you can
derive from number Theory purpose
principles and our brain is discovering
our brain is basically discovering a
useful set of functions to model any
sting a set of useful computational
Primitives and we can probably give our
deep Learning Systems a library of
predefined Primitives to speed up their
convergence that's also the reason why
there is useful transfer learning
between different domains you can train
a vision model
and use it as a pre-trained zoom for
audio and it's not because it's the same
thing but because it has learned useful
computational Primitives that it can
apply across domains
but there is geometry in the audio
signal
so this is very interesting territory I
hope uh you know I hope you'll come back
uh to dive into this a bit more deeply
when we have when we have more time and
a better connection because I agree with
you I think yeah let's put that some
very fascinating you know math here
fantastic well um Dr Joshua Bach it's as
I said You by far the most requested
guest
um that we've had right from the very
beginning so it's it's an honest fun to
get you on the show and I hope we can
get you back soon for a longer
conversation thank you so much
likewise I enjoyed this very much let's
meet again soon